Apple's 13-inch MacBook Pro has now been
refreshed for 2020 but it seems like all
the attention is on the higher end
eighteen hundred dollar model since
that's the model that features Intel's
latest tenth gen processors but I think
people are way over exaggerating how
important those chips really are I've
even seen people recommending the 2020
MacBook Air over the base MacBook Pro
just because of the tension processors
which is a massive mistake and I'll
explain why in just a minute now I'm not
saying that the new $1,800 MacBook Pro
isn't a great choice in fact I think
it's definitely worth the extra $500
over the 20/20 base model mainly because
you get a 512 guess SD and 16 gigs of
ram included which those upgrades used
to cost $400 alone and on top of that
you get other great features like much
better speakers better cooling thanks to
an extra fan to extra ports and of
course better performance but the
reality is that not everyone wants to
spend almost $2,000 for a macbook and
for those who can afford the $1,300 pro
they'll be making an excellent choice
despite the hñ processor and what
reviewers are saying about it I
personally think the real mistake is
thinking that the 20/20 MacBook Air with
a quad core i5 or even the i7 processor
will have better performance than this
base macbook pro thanks to the
all-powerful 10th gen ship but that's
simply not true
the main reason for that is because
Apple decided not to connect the MacBook
Airs fan to the CPUs heatsink so even
the dual core i3 model hits a hundred
degrees Celsius relatively quickly let
alone the i7 and when we ran our CPU
stress test the MacBook Air suffered
because of the lack of cooling with the
base macbook pro pulley way ahead so
here's my take on the MacBook Air versus
the MacBook Pro if you care about
performance whatsoever by the base
MacBook Pro instead so that means if
you're considering the quad-core
model of the MacBook Air you actually do
care about performance so by the base
MacBook Pro instead trust me it will
perform much better
despite the a gen chip and the fans will
stay quieter as well and yes the
long-awaited fortune' inch MacBook Pro
is in the works but more and more rumors
and leaks are appointing to at least a
spring 2021 release date and the reality
is that a lot of people aren't going to
wait that long so let's get into why I
think this 20/20 base 13-inch MacBook
Pro is still a great choice right now
first off the main issue with the 2019
model was the butterfly keyboard and
that is now fixed with the 2020 model
since it gets the new magic keyboard and
there truly is a massive difference in
the quality of the keyboard and
everything from key travel and typing
experience to reliability as well
and another nice addition is that we now
get a physical Escape key so it's much
more convenient to use than before but
other than with the keyboard you won't
find any other physical difference
except for the tiny increase in weight
and thickness compared to the 2019 model
well of course it'd be nice to have that
14 inch redesigned right now but we
can't blame Apple because the 14 inch
model was never anything more than
rumours from the supply chain and then
blogging sites took those rumours and
decided to get everybody hyped up making
them think that it's coming this year so
we shouldn't blame Apple we should
actually be thanking them because this
base 8 gen model has become a much
better deal especially for those who
want 16 gigs of ram with a 2019 model if
you wanted 256 gigs of storage and 16
gigabytes of RAM you'd have to spend
$1,700 to get it but now the 256 gig SSD
is already included in the base price
and upgrading to 16 gigs of ram is now
only a $100 upgrade so you're saving
$300 compared to last year to get the
same specs and you're getting the
reliable magic keyboard which is even
more important for some people so we
definitely are getting a pretty good
value this you
with the base MacBook Pro but there's
one question left that we need to answer
does the old eighth generation chip make
this MacBook Pro a bad choice well if
you've seen our recent $1300 versus
$1,800 20/20 MacBook Pro comparison
video you'll know that the tangential
isn't massively faster than the base
eight gen like everyone is making a
sound like we only saw around a 12%
higher Geekbench five CPU score on the
Tenjin which translated to around 24%
better performance in the Cinebench r20
stress test now that is a decent
improvement but if you don't have 1,800
dollars to spend on a MacBook Pro you're
still getting very impressive processing
performance with the base model that'll
actually be enough for a wide variety of
people like programmers photo editors
logic pro users and maybe even video
editors now the big difference between
these two is graphics power where we saw
a 48 percent higher metal graphics score
on the $1,800 model this is actually a
really big difference but keep in mind
that this will only improve graphics
work like video editing and 3d rendering
so photo editors programmers and logic
pro users won't see any significant
performance gains from the extra
graphics power and even for video
editing running the Bruce X test the
$1,800 model was surprisingly only 20%
faster than the base model a much
smaller difference than we expected so
the base model keeps up surprisingly
well but one thing that the better
graphics and the higher-end model does
improve is gaming performance Greg from
Greg's gadgets showed off how that
$1,800 model was able to play some games
at decent frame rates like League of
Legends counter-strike go fortnight and
more but keep in mind that he ran each
of these games at 1440 by 900 resolution
which is only 31 percent of the MacBook
Pros native resolution of 2560 by 1600
so if you want decent FPS for gaming
while at higher resolutions then you're
either gonna have to go for a 16 inch
MacBook Pro which has a dedicated
graphics card or you'll have to set up
an a GPU instead and if you do go the
a GPU route it actually makes much more
sense to buy the base $1,300 model with
16 gigabytes of RAM for $1400
since the e GPU takes the integrated
graphics of the Intel chips out of the
equation completely so if you're
interested to see how that will perform
then click the subscribe button and
enable notifications because that video
is coming soon the point I'm trying to
make is that the difference in
performance between this base model and
the higher-end $1800 model isn't as big
as people are making it out to be the
base model has more than enough
performance for those who can't afford
to spend $1,800 on the higher-end
MacBook Pro however for some people
spending the extra cash really does make
a lot of sense like for video editors or
people who want more value thanks to the
other improvements like better speakers
faster RAM and two more ports but if you
can't see yourself spending that much
cash don't feel bad about choosing the
base model instead I would just strongly
recommend upgrading to 16 gigabytes of
RAM for only $100 it's an excellent deal
and it'll help for everything from video
editing programming photo editing Logic
Pro 10 and also for people like me who
love having a lot of chrome tabs open at
once so with the base macbook pro you're
getting a bright display with great p3
color gamut you'll get the new reliable
magic keyboard an excellent trackpad
more stores than before and much better
real-world performance than any of the
MacBook Airs
even the i7 model now if you're someone
who already has a laptop that's working
just fine and you can easily wait a full
year for the 14-inch redesigned then I
would recommend doing so but for
everyone else who can't wait that long
the base macbook pro is an excellent
laptop for the price if you enjoy this
review go ahead and tap the like button
and click the circle above to subscribe
so you don't miss out on those
GPU videos coming soon thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]